I take it that there are people who have
you spoke of dying for something who has
nothing to live for died for defense
mechanisms or whatever in fact professor
Smith I must say that there is a growing
incidence of a feeling of total and
ultimate meaninglessness of life while
acting worthwhile nests of one's life
the abysmal feeling of that of an inner
void and emptiness and many people above
all among the academic youth is caught
in this crippling and tantalizing
experience of that there is no meaning
to human existence at all this emptiness
this boredom this inner void I've termed
the existential vacuum the frustration
that is to say of that way to meaning or
which I've started to speak I'm very
curious at this point you have been a
frequent visitor to our country do you
notice any difference between students
in Europe and those in the United States
on precisely this point of the sense of
life emptiness and meaningless certainly
for instance once I improvising ly
conducted a statistical inquiry and
research among my students at the
Medical School of Vienna University
students from I'm lecturing in German
that is to say West German Austrian
Swiss students and so forth and up to a
percentage of 40% they are not not 14 14
why they admitted that they knew from
their own experience this duet fool
abysmal feeling of a total and ultimate
meaninglessness in life and then and
this might be still more interesting to
you then I conducted the same experiment
among my American students
whom I'm lecturing in English at the
University of Vienna and the percentage
of those who confess that they knew from
their own experience this existential
vacuum was not forty but eighty one
percent
well now curse this immediately cries
out for an explanation of why partially
this might be you last but not least to
this entirely and thoroughly mechanistic
approach which is so prevalent and so
predominant in your culture and in your
way and manner of approaching students
of teaching what I mean is that you
youngsters are told and taught that in
the final analysis man is nothing but
the battleground of conflicting of
crashing games of an e ego and super-ego
Oh in the final analysis nothing but I'm
stressing nothing but the outcome the
mere outcome of various conditioning
processes be that we then have to deal
with sociological conditions or with
conditions of psychological or
biological nature and foraging this
might be one of the causes accountable
for this present state of affairs from
the way you think about that it sounds I
gather that you're totally opposed to
this view is man then not cause there
are no conditioning going on as a
condition you may be sure that I'm fully
aware of that man is also determined and
conditions what I'm against what I'm
pleading against is solely time
determinism as I used to call her that
is to say regarding man is fully
conditioned and determined and as in my
other quality you
it's lied to me not as a professor in
two disciplines but as a survival for
German concentration camps I can tell
you that purely man is subject to
conditions man is not at all treatment
conditions but man is always free to
take expand throughout whatsoever
conditions
he might have he might be confronted
with and in this taking a stand and to
this precisely to this very extent he is
free he there is choice of which
attitude to adopt whenever confronted
with an unchangeable situation and when
you are teaching people and preaching
that man is to be human existence is
similarly to be explained in terms
either of the Machine model or the what
model I'm quoting now god W or thought
then you should no longer be surprised
and us astonished when people finally
really behave like automata they've
never been taught art and told anything
else this reminds me of this story which
I recently have in Vienna of a man who
wanted to train his parrot that this
parrot might say daddy to him and this
parrot did not do anything like this and
in order to punish the parrot he jailed
it overnight in the henhouse and when he
visited the hen house in the morning he
found all chickens killed by the parrot
and the last living chicken the parrot
parrot in its cows and best it and
scream say it to me painted it to me he
just behaved as had been taught and told
by his own